[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute gibt es ein rezept was auf meinen
hut oder zeit basics aufbaut
also wenn ihr dieses rezept nach machen
wollt macht auf jeden fall zuerst einmal
meinen nudel rezept am besten in
verschiedenen farben heute gibt es
nämlich lars sanierungs oder einfach
modeln utl strudel nur das studio hat
sich auch gut an und zwar ich hier
bereits vier verschiedene nudelsorten
basilikum curcuma rote beete und tomaten
nudeln gemacht und diese zu langen
lasagne platten ausgerollt und 50
zentimeter langen zugeschnitten
die brauche ich später erst ich habe sie
aber schon mal vorbereitet und die
werden dann gefüllt mit einer
hackfleisch masse auberginen und
zucchini
ich sage euch mal was ich dafür brauche
ich habe ich meine acht lasagne platten
für die füllung brauche ich 500 gramm
hackfleisch 2 knoblauchzehen eine
zwiebel etwas olivenöl 800 gramm tomaten
aus der dose
ich habe ich tomatenmark und jede
gewürze ich brauche etwas zucker salz
pfeffer chili paprikapulver basilikum
und oregano für die würze nämlich einen
feta käse und 2 zucchini und zwei uhren
die zwiebel und knoblauchzehe habe ich
bereits gehört wird jetzt kann ich das
hackfleisch anbraten hier in einem topf
einfach olivenöl erhitzen hackfleisch
dazu und könig anbraten
[Musik]
jetzt kommen hier noch die knoblauch und
zwiebel würfeln mit rein und werden für
etwas zwei minuten mit angebraten
jetzt kommt hier noch die tomatensoße
rein also tomaten kartoffeln
die nehme ich immer ganz gerne weil es
einfach super intensiv sind
tomatenmark und die gewürze und dann
kann ich jetzt die sauce aufkochen
lassen und bei geringer hitze etwa 10
minuten köcheln lassen
und in der zwischenzeit werde ich die
auberginen und zucchini in ganz ganz
feine scheiben hobeln
[Musik]
ich mache das ganze jetzt hier mit
seinem bauhof und da kann ich die
zucchini einfach so ein bisschen
reingeben reindrücken
da muss man mich immer auf die schwinger
aufpassen und dann schön fein hobeln
[Musik]
hier seht ihr jetzt die platten sind
richtig schön dünn und auch flexibel und
die werde ich jetzt mit salz und pfeffer
würzen
[Musik]
jetzt ist die soße fertig hat ja auch
abgeschmeckt als er mich jetzt einfach
mal probieren ob genug salz und pfeffer
drinnen ist jetzt kommt er direkt in
eine auflaufform und wenn ihr den
gusseisernen topf habt könnt ihr dieses
eben gusseisernen topf zu bereiten und
später dann auch darin die nudel rollen
eben auch backen
[Musik]
jetzt geht's ans rollen ich nehme meinen
lasagne platten kann die arbeitsflächen
bisschen bemühen und dann die platten
hier aus räumt und ich echt super
praktisch mit der dauer back folie
[Musik]
jetzt lege ich hier die zucchinischeiben
und die auberginen scheiben drauf
[Musik]
und jetzt nämlich den käse da nehme ich
jetzt einen feta käse und der ist fass
gereift und hat einen richtig tollen
intensiven geschmack der aber jetzt
nicht alles über wird und er passt hier
perfekt rein gerade weil die zucchini ja
auch so ein bisschen süßlich ist und so
bekommt ihr eine richtig tolle würze
hier rein
[Musik]
und so können die lasagne rollen jetzt
sind vorgeheizten backofen gebacken
werden und ich lasse jetzt komplett
abgedeckt damit die nudeln auch wirklich
schön gar werden
[Musik]
so sehen die rollen jetzt angerichtet
aus ich finde es dennoch ein bisschen
aus wie rosen kann ich nicht besorgt so
er sagt kann das tun aber auch darauf
wie auch dass kinder was sieht er auch
in einer form auflaufen
ja das sieht so genial aus ja das macht
erfährt er ist ein bisschen vorteile
weil die oper gehen bringt oder zucchini
tja und das mit stolz heraus und ist ja
dazu immer ganz gerne joghurt und immer
den zehnprozentigen joghurt also ich
probiere ich meine vorstellung geht ok
eigentlich probiert mal alles zusammen
hwk genial so das model
diese sieht auch die tür gesetzt ist ja
dass nur eins davor aber ich probiere es
einfach es ist ein tag den ich mit
tomatenmark gemacht habe basilikum
kurkuma rote beete und war cool oder
auberginen beispiel wie ich finde
tormaschinerie schon mal inneren eines
lego schuhs gerufen
oh gott nein wahrscheinlich krank und
pervers aber ich glaube ich zwar aber
das merkt richtig tollen muss er sich ja
und ich finde es nicht auch ein rezept
das kann man ja auch super vorbereitet
man kann ja auch die hackfleischsoße zum
beispiel schon einen tag vorher zu
bereiten und im kühlschrank lagern die
rollen kann man auch wunderbar am morgen
zu bereiten
und dann ist ganze gericht im
kühlschrank lagern und dann wenn ihr zu
abend essen möchte dann wirklich ein
tolles rezept von ramadan gern weil man
es eben toll vorbereiten kann und es
wirklich auch etwas hermacht also falls
ihr das rezept ausprobieren wollt dann
geht auf meinem blog fällig - blog.de
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen wünschen guten appetit und
wir sehen uns wieder das nächste mal
könnten wir anderen farben also ja ich
glaube dass mccarthy hackfleischsoße und
die wohnung und in der rolle ist er noch
der schafskäse ndash genial oder soll
den muss man auf jeden fall also gar
nicht gekommen ich kann es nicht ich
finde diese steuer ist aber ich mache
das die man aufbauen kann schon jetzt
ein film
ich weiß noch ein schuss gesagt aber
hier ok macht nächste thema gespräche
noch weiter selbst
geld mit dem sich nur ein
geschmackserlebnis nicht von außen nach
innen warnt holen also kommt alles für
tisch meeresniveau zum käsen hat okay
[Musik]